i want to thank everybody in this
country who is coming forward to get
vaccinated that's the way i look at it
and you know the
this country is quite extraordinary
there was a poll i think
done last night which showed that of all
the countries in the world we are the
most
positive about vaccinations the numbers
are incredibly high
and i know that uh you know some people
have been more vaccine
hesitant than than others but actually
across the whole of society the numbers
continue
to go up in every group in every age
group
and that's very very encouraging and i
would urge everybody just make the
obvious point uh urge everybody who is
eligible
for a vaccine when you get your your
call up when you get the
the notification for the nhs can we get
your jab what'd you say to those many in
your own party who are saying we can't
halt the unlocking for the sake of those
who are refusing to get a vaccine
i i just go back to the point i i made
about where we are
on the on the road map we're looking
very carefully at the
the data we're looking at what's
happening the epidemiology
uh where we're trying to work out to
what extent
uh the new variant the indian variant
may be more transmissible
but at the moment we see nothing
conclusive to say that we have to
to deviate from the roadmap but
obviously we'll be keeping people
informed that's why
i said what i said on friday and we'll
keep people continually
updating well we're looking at the uh
epidemiology
the whole time as it comes in and
at the moment i think partly because we
built up such a
a wall of defenses with the vaccination
program
i don't see anything conclusive at the
moment to say that we need to
deviate from the roadmap but we we've
got to be cautious
and we're keeping everything under very
close observation
we'll know a lot more in a few days time
so it's not changing your approach yet
we're keeping everything under very very
careful close
review we're looking at all the data as
it comes in
from places like bolton blackburn
bedford theft and other places just
looking at those curves where they're
they're moving trying to understand
whether the
indian variant is more transmissible and
if so
by how much more it's transmissible and
also trying to understand to what extent
uh our vaccine program has already
sufficiently fortified us all
against it and uh i'm afraid we just got
a few more days of
looking at that data but as things stand
at the moment i can see nothing
conclusive in the data to say that we
have to deviate from the from the
present roadmap but we've got to be
cautious and
we'll be letting people know in a few
days time can you rule out to return to
local lockdowns
we just got to be cautious about the way
we
approach it and we'll be letting people
know
as much as we can as soon as we can but
at the moment we don't see
anything conclusive that makes us think
we have to
to deviate from the road map obviously
we'll be letting people know as soon as
we've we've got the data
your own nhs test and trace data shows
that in late march early april travelers
returning from india had higher coveted
positivity than bangladesh
only marginally lower than pakistan they
brought back more variants of concern or
interest than any other country in the
world
why then did you wait a further two
weeks before putting india on the red
list
well if you look at what actually
happened with the
variant that we're talking about the the
so-called
indian variant the b one six one seven
point two
uh this india was put on the
the red list before this was even a
variant under his under investigation
let alone a variant of concern
so we took uh prompt action and we will
continue to take uh
very very draconian action in respect of
all variants coming from
wherever around the world why are the
rules on international travel
currently so wooly you've got 150
flights a day going to ambulance
countries do you think that's safe
i think it's very important for people
to to grasp what an ambulance
country is it is not somewhere where you
should be going
on on holiday but let me be very clear
about that and
if people uh do go to to enable this
country they absolutely
have to for uh some pressing family or
uh or urgent business reasons they have
to go to an annualist
country then please bear in mind that
you will have to self-isolate you'll
have to take
tests and do a passenger locator form
and all the rest of it
but you'll also have to self-isolate for
10 days
when you get back and that period of
self-isolation
that period of quarantine will be
enforced with fines of
of up to ten thousand pounds so i think
it's important people understand
what an ambulance country is george user
said this morning it's okay to go to
ambulance countries to visit family and
friends
was he wrong i think it's very important
for people to understand
that if you go to an hour but this
country if you absolutely have to go
for some uh pressing uh reason uh
not a holiday if you have to go then
bear in mind you're gonna have to pay
for testing uh you're gonna have to do
passenger location all that kind of
thing but you're also
going to have to self-isolate for 10
days
at home not going out and if you fail to
obey that then
you will face a fines of up to ten
thousand pounds so people need to
understand
that an amber list country is definitely
not a green list country